[Applauso]
[Musica]
ho sorte Sei come la luna dallo Stato
variabile che sempre cresce e sempre
decresci ho vita detestabile
questi versetti così drammatici che
entrano in scandiscono il poema del
Carmina Burana con Toni veramente
tragici e drammatici sono risuonati
nella mia anima e sono vibrati nella mia
anima nel momento in cui ho pensato
Working future e mi sono fatta questa
domanda Ma quale futuro possiamo pensare
quando già il presente si prospetta
incerto si prospetta volatile si
prospetta complesso ed ambigua viviamo
questa realtà che è una realtà che per
natura è veramente lontana dalla
condizione dell'essere umano Chiama per
natura ricercare la stabilità e la
sicurezza Eppure noi viviamo veramente
su una realtà magmatica e assolutamente
instabile che ci fa tremare le gambe e
ci fa tremare le gambe pensare ad un
futuro così incerto
Eppure oggi come 800 anni fa quando i
monaci benedettini
scrissero il poema dei Carmina Burana E
come da sempre nella vita dell'umanità
siamo anche oggi chiamati a realizzare
il nostro futuro a costruire il nostro
futuro
bene io vi parlerò questa sera del ruolo
della funzione HR all'interno delle
organizzazioni aziendali impegnata
veramente nella costruzione del futuro
nell'accompagnare il futuro delle nostre
organizzazioni un ruolo quello delle
Charme che solo ora Dopo la pandemia
acquisito veramente una posizione
strategica che non aveva mai avuto prima
io ve ne parlerò passando un po' in
rassegna la mia vita professionale degli
ultimi 30 anni dove ho vissuto
l'evoluzione la mutazione di questa
funzione Ma poi per soffermarmi su
quella che è la mission oggi di una
funzione hichar accompagnare lo
stravolgimento dei cambiamenti che
viviamo in ogni momento
e quindi
vi porto in questo luogo Un po' magico
Siamo in un Chiostro medievale che è
divenuto poi un Ateneo Lombardo E siamo
nel 1995
davanti a me il filosofo che stavo
correggendo l'ultimo capitolo della mia
tesi di laurea critica e fondazione
della logica in usser lì L'allieva già
pregustava il suo futuro in una
biblioteca Universitaria del nord Europa
intenta alla costruzione scientifica del
mondo filosofiche e teoretica e così
L'allieva prende il coraggio e
interpella l'oracolo professore per
favore mi dica quale sarà il mio futuro
e rimase così sospesa per qualche
impermeabile secondo in attesa dalla
profezia dell'oracolo e il professore e
guardò L'allieva e disse Vai e immergiti
nella profondità inesauribile del mondo
vai e tocca con mano la fondazione extra
filosofica dell'esistenza umana
Dopodiché Fra 30 anni potrei tornare a
occuparti di filosofia
non compresi assolutamente nulla di
quello che disse il filosofo in quel
momento ma davanti a cotanta Sapienza
L'allieva si affidò e così cosa fece
abbandono la sicurezza di quel Chiostro
medievale si lasciò le spalle
l'università
[Musica]
e si tuffò nell'abisso del mondo
completamente sconosciuto e mi piace
pensare veramente a questa immagine che
trovo devo dire commovente perché
rappresenta
l'iniziazione dell'uomo
siamo nel quinto secolo avanti Cristo ed
è fa parte proprio di un reperto
archeologico che è stato ritrovato nel
sito archeologico di Paestum E questa
immagine l'immagine di un giovane che
prende il coraggio e si butta
nell'oceano davanti agli adulti dando
questa prova di coraggio quindi va
proprio la scoperta di quello che è il
mondo e io mi sento proprio un po' così
in quel momento
quando poi riemersi dall'abisso io mi
ritrovai esattamente qua lo scenario era
abbastanza inquietante perché mi
ritrovai a iniziare a muovere i primi
passi del Richard nel settore
informatico siamo proprio gli albori
dell'anno 2000 Millennium bug e quindi i
media inizieranno a lanciare un po' di
informazioni terroristiche su quello che
sarebbe successo nel passaggio del
millennio l'anno 2000
non successe proprio nulla cioè tutto
passò tranquillo serenamente varcammo
l'anno 2000 e io mi ritrovai in questa
funzione HR esattamente un bivio da una
parte siamo chiamiamo così nell'epoca
post industriale da una parte
sussistevano ancora delle organizzazioni
burocratiche incentrate proprio sul
profitto nel breve termine sul controllo
sulle procedure e che
quindi mettevano proprio al centro di
questa organizzazione ovviamente il
business il capitale finanziario e una
certa entità chiamata workforce la forza
lavoro un'entità da controllare no e da
gestire
dall'altra parte però stavano iniziando
a nascere degli organismi all'interno
dei quali si facevano stradelline e
guida su Cultura comportamenti e valori
e in buona sostanza si cominciava a
parlare di capitale umano
Ebbene ci sono due immagini che vorrei
suggerirvi proprio per andare a sentire
proprio questo passaggio no e da una
parte vediamo
raffigurata la opera di Magritte Secondo
me rappresenta lo dico
La solitudine dell'Omo economico
assolutamente tetra come scenario mette
anche un po' di inquietudine siamo Negli
anni cinquanta l'opera del 1953 quindi
pieno Boom economico e dall'altra parte
invece troviamo geroglifico che va a
rappresentare invece è la nascita
dell'Omo Sapiens Quindi quello che io
vissi in quel momento e senti in quel
momento era veramente la transizione di
organizzazioni che passavano da
organismi economici dediti
esclusivamente al profitto e al
controllo del capitale finanziario ha
organismi invece che si occupavano della
gestione del capitale umano quello che
io ebbi la fortuna di sentire in questo
momento era Finalmente
il fatto che il capitale umano per la
prima volta iniziava ad avere almeno una
pari dignità del capitale finanziario
bene molto rapidamente il nostro povero
Richard passò dal funzionario paghe
contributi dell'era arcaica al capo del
personale dell'era moderna al
responsabile delle risorse umane che
invece già No iniziava proprio a
preannunciare la leadership umanistica
delle hit
che è sopraggiunto con la turbolenza
della pandemia dove veramente ha
iniziato a giocare una partita veramente
importante e in prima linea
e mi piace
pensare a quello che sta accadendo in
questo momento
in questo momento soffia forte il vento
irruento irrequieto ibrido e vitale del
cambiamento
che ha accelerato dalla pandemia e che
ci sta portando alla luce delle potenti
verità dalle quali ci stavamo
allontanando e quindi la meraviglia
e la fragilità della natura umana e del
nostro pianeta che rappresentano
l'organizzazione che rappresentano il
cuore e l'anima della nostra vita e
della nostra organizzazione
Noi abbiamo toccato con mano in questi
ultimi due anni
sconvolti dalla pandemia abbiamo toccato
con mano che la vita è un'avventura ma è
unica ed è fragile Ed è proprio su
questa presa di coscienza che si colloca
la funzione strategica delle HR che ha
uno sguardo Se volete privilegiato
proprio nell'andare a sentire a
percepire quello che sta accadendo nel
mondo e nelle organizzazioni in questo
momento e che quindi sente e percepisce
che Deve necessariamente trasformarsi e
Cambiare pelle e trasformare le
organizzazioni nelle quali oggi stiamo
vivendo Deve prima di tutto abbandonare
quella che è la divisa da pompiere molto
spesso lei Charles è la spalla su cui
piangere piuttosto che colui che Eva e
rincorre i problemi che spesso non
vengono lasciati lì nell'organizzazione
non Curati da una leadership molto
spesso assente piuttosto piuttosto che
il cappello della maestrina che èva
rincorrere gli allievi di sci
indisciplinati bene
il leader il leader Richard oggi deve
invece prendere la coscienza che deve
andare a costruire
un'organizzazione e un ambiente di
lavoro veramente ricca proprio di
significato all'interno del quale un
modello di business in continua
evoluzione possa veramente attecchire E
il nostro leader Richard deve poter
accompagnare una nuova leadership che
possa valorizzare il capitale umano
e mi piace poter dire che il nostro
leader HR dovrà prima di tutto creare
dei luoghi del senso all'interno delle
organizzazioni
dei luoghi all'interno delle quali i
talenti le fragilità le competenze le
attitudini i sogni di tutti i
collaboratori possono essere Curati
accolti valorizzati integrati e
aumentati
un luogo all'interno del quale vi sarà
spazio e vi può essere spazio per una
leadership necessariamente umanistica un
luogo all'interno del quale
dovremo necessariamente mettere da parte
leader
orientati esclusivamente al proprio
potere personale alla propria Gloria
personale e
al profitto nel medio termine
leader invece che vadano oltre se stessi
si dimentichino di se stessi e si
occupino delle persone da far crescere
all'interno dell'organizzazione
un luogo all'interno del quale
Sofia possa avere la propria
realizzazione e Sofia è una giovanissima
candidata che ho incontrato recentemente
alla quale chiesi Sofia ma che cosa
vorrebbe fare all'interno di questo
organizzazione lei Mi guardò con gli
occhi sgranati e mi disse Ma guardi
è qualcosa di importante Vorrei lasciare
una traccia Anzi no guardi Io vorrei
fare qualcosa di epocale ed è una
giovanissima di di vent'anni di poco più
di vent'anni fare qualcosa focale Allora
io mi domando
e vi confesso quell'incontro cambiò
l'andamento della mia giornata e delle
giornate successive mi diede tanta luce
e mi diede veramente tanta speranza però
mi fece anche pensare a questo ma
oggi le nostre organizzazioni
sono pronte per accogliere tante
innovazione e tanto capitale umano
perché il quesito è proprio questo oggi
una leadership sarà proprio valutata su
questo sulla capacità di attrarre
giovani di attrarre giovani talenti con
i loro sogni perché oggi tutti i grandi
leader aziendali dicono Beh la nostra
azienda è aperta e giovani Integra i
giovani salvo poi snobbarli pagarli
veramente molto poco e non prenderli in
considerazione e non favorirne
l'integrazione all'interno di una
struttura organizzativa e culturale
anche importante
la nuova leadership e char e quindi
tutto l'organizzazione aziendale sarà
valutata sulla reputazione aziendale
sarà valutata sulla reputazione interna
ed esterna a partire dal liceo stesso e
io spesso mi trovo a parlare con con il
mio team dicendo ragazzi siate
consapevoli di questo se avete scelto
questo mestiere il mestiere di Richard
Ma voi primi dovete essere dei roll
Model dovete essere co soggetti rispetto
ai valori che state comunicando e quindi
è una Mission speciale particolare ricca
di responsabilità e dovremmo anche
essere coscienti che saremo valutati su
sulla coerenza
alla nostra azienda è assolutamente
innovativa e Smart salvo poi affollare i
server di lunghezza e allegati o
intossicare l'organizzazione di
lunghissime videocolle ama la nostra
azienda tiene tantissimo alla felicità
dei propri collaboratori salvo poi
avere dei collaboratori gestiti da capi
tossici e molto poco Sapiens coerenza
saremo valutati sul Trust sulla
trasparenza saremo valutati
sull'integrità saremo valutati sulle
eticità
il leader umanista delle risorse umane
sarà colui sarà custode del capitale
umano e avrà la responsabilità di
accompagnare la nuova leadership
umanistica con l'obiettivo di
valorizzare i talenti di ciascuno
integrare tutte le competenze fare in
modo che ogni individuo provi gioia e
realizzi il proprio progetto individuale
di vita perché Ricordiamoci una cosa che
il bisogno più antico dell'essere umano
il bisogno dell'anima più antico
dell'essere umano è vivere una vita
speciale significativa ricca di senso e
sono queste le organizzazioni che
dobbiamo creare luoghi nei quali tutti
gli individui vogliano stare lavorare e
condividere e provare gioia
e quindi
e arrivo alla conclusione di questa
storia
vi invito a ripensare
un po' al ritmo incalzante del Carmine a
Burana che ha aperto questo intervento
ma non ha soffermarvi sul sulla
tragicità delle parole concentratevi
invece chiudendo gli occhi concentratevi
invece sulle voci sui suoni sui ritmi e
iniziate a pensare a come queste anime
si stanno sincronizzando ognuna di
queste singole anime sta realizzando la
propria opera individuale sta provando
Gioia ma prova una gioia ancora più
grande nel momento in cui viene connessa
all'interno di questo organismo di
intelligenza collettiva e con tutte le
altre anime per la creazione di una
composizione polifonica sicuramente ad
alta performance e in re maggiore perché
re maggiore è la tonalità della vitalità
e dell'energia creativa e realizzativa
ascoltiamolo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
certo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Eccola Questa è la grande opera che si
realizza nel re maggiore
[Musica]
un'opera straordinariamente collettiva
Grazie
[Applauso]